يناقش مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي في وزاره
الدفاع في تل ابيب شروط حركه حماس من اجل
اتمام صفقه لتبادل الاسر في وقت يصر فيه
رئيس الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو على مواصله
الحرب ويلوح بشن عمليه عسكريه في رفح من
اجل الضغط على حركه حماس عسكريا يؤكد
نتنياهو رفض اسرائيل الخضوع لمطالب حركه
حماس في المقابل يطالب الوزير في مجلس
الحرب بيني جانس بوضع ملف الاسرى
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في غزه
كاولو قصوى ومن المتوقع ان يلتئم المجلس
الوزري للشؤون الامنيه والسياسيه بعد
انتهاء اجتماع مجلس
الحرب معنا من تل ابيب مراسله الجزيره
فاطمه خمايسه فاطمه هل رشح اي جديد عن هذا
الاجتماع نعم السي حتى هذه اللحظه لا يوجد
اي تفاصيل اضافيه حول مخرجات هذا الاجتماع
ولا نعلم حتى هذه اللحظه ان كان قد انتهى
اجتماع اعضاء مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي في
وزاره الدفاع في مدينه تل ابيب وان كان قد
بدا ايضا اجتماع المجلس الوزاري المصغر
للشؤون الامنيه والسياسيه ولكن هذا في
حقيقه الامر ليس بغريب خاصه وانه يتم
مناقشه الشروط التي وضعتها حركه حماس
لصفقه لتبادل الاسرى وبالتالي هذا الموضوع
جدا حساس لديه تداعيات ايضا جدا كبيره على
مستوى الداخل الاسرائيلي والذي انعكس على
الشارع الاسرائيلي نتحدث عن تنظيم مظاهرات
من قبل عائلات الاسرى الاسرائيليين مقابل
وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه كنوع من الضغط
على اعضاء مجلس الحرب للذهاب نحو اتمام
الصفقه لتبادل سراح الاسرى واطلاق سراح
الاسرى الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في غزه في
المقابل كان هنالك ايضا الالاف يتظاهرون
في مدينه القدس ويطالبون الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بمواصله الحرب على قطاع غزه
وفقط عبر مواصله الحرب سيتم اعاده الاسرى
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في القطاع
وبالتالي نرى انه حتى على مستوى الشارع
الاسرائيلي هنالك شرخ هنالك انقسام وايضا
على مستوى المجلس الوزاري ومجلس الحرب
هنالك انقسام وتفاوت في وجهات النظر ما
بين رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامين
نتنياهو الذي يقول علانيه ان على اسرائيل
عدم الخضوع لشروط حركه حماس ولكن من ناحيه
اخرى لم يغلق باب المباحثات والمفاوضات و
زالت مستمره من اجل اتمام صفقه يعني تقدم
في نهايه الامر لاطلاق صراح الاسرى
الاسرائيليين ولكن من ناحيه اخرى نتحدث عن
تلويح ايضا بنيامين نتنياهو بمواصله
العمليه العسكريه وايضا شن عمليه عسكريه
في منطقه رفح المكتظه بالاف اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين والنازحين في تلك المنطقه
وطبعا هذا الامر يثير تخوف المجتمع الدولي
وايضا الاداره الامريكيه طبعا كان ايضا قد
تواجد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني
بلينكن والذي كشفت صحيفه ارتس انه كان
ينوي زياره معبر كرم ابو سالم ليتفقد
كيفيه ادخال المساعدات الانسانيه الى قطاع
غزه ولكن هنالك يوميا مظاهرات من قبل
اليمين الاسرائيلي المتطرف يقومون بعرق
دخول هذه المساعدات وقام بلينكن بطلب عدم
عرقله دخول هذه المساعدات وبالتالي عندما
قامت الشرطه الاسرائيليه بمواصله السماح
لهؤلاء المتظاهرين بالتجمهر والتجمع في
تلك المنطقه قام انتوني بلينكن بالغاء هذه
الزياره المقرره الى تلك المنطقه يوم امس
وبالتالي نرى ان هنالك حتى على مستوى
الشارع مظاهرات في اماكن مختلفه ولاسباب
مختلفه نتحدث عن مظاهرات في معبر كرم ابو
سالم لعرقله دخول المساعدات وللضغط على
حركه حماس في المقابل مظاهرات في القدس
تطالب وتدعم الحكومه الاسرائيليه وترفض
الذهاب والتوجه نحو صفقه وفي المقابل في
مدينه تلبيب هنالك مظاهرات تطالب باقاله
الحكومه والتوجه الى انتخابات فوريه وايضا
بابرام صفقه لاطلاق راح الاسرى وبالتالي
هذا هو المشهد هنا على مستوى الداخل
الاسرائيلي هنالك يعني تعقيدات جدا كبيره
وهذا الامر يعني يتزامن ايضا مع التطورات
في قطاع غزه على المستوى الميداني ايضا
القناه الثال ع الاسرائيليه قد كشفت بان
بنيامين نتنياهو قام بتوبيخ اعضاء الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ووزرائه وقام بلومه لماذا لم
يقوم بانتقاد ومهاجمه الصفقه المحتمله
وبالتالي نرى ان هنالك محاوله من بنيامين
نتنيا ان يظهر الى العلن برفض هذه الصفقه
من ناحيه ومن ناحيه اخرى يحاول ايضا ان
يظهر وان يعطي وان يبقي الباب مفتوح مقابل
لهذه المفاوضات والمباحثات حتى هذه اللحظه
كما ذكرت بما ان الموضوع حساس وهنالك ترقب
جدا عالي هنالك رقابه وعدم وجود اي
تسريبات حول هذا الموضوع كما اعتدنا سابقا
كان هنالك العديد من التسريبات في هذه
الجلسات التي تناقش ايه سير العمليه في
قطاع غزه من الناحيه العسكريه ايضا ادخال
المساعدات وتلك الامور ولكن الوضع الان
بات بشكل مغاير وبشكل مختلف لا يوجد اي
تسريبات حتى هذه اللحظه ولا نعلم ان كان
الاجتماع قد انتهى وقد بدا الاجتماع الاخر
الذي من المتوقع ان يناقش ايضا ادخال عدد
اضافي من العمال الفلسطينيين لتدارك
الخسائر الاقتصاديه التي يعني تسب سبت
فيها الحرب